[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais voilà ça c'est internet
en tout cas c'est le cliché qui en
ressort ou en clichés pas complètement
faux puisqu'il faut bien reconnaître que
sur les réseaux sociaux
il ya beaucoup de vidéos de chats ou
d'animaux mignons de vidéos qui sont
futiles et pas forcément très utile mais
les choses évoluent et heureusement
et aujourd'hui ce que les internautes
recherchent c'est du sens est ce que les
médias véhiculent c'est du sens et ce
sens il nous a en partie était imposé
par les évolutions d'abord
technologiques les évolutions des
plateformes sociales à commencer par
facebook
et puis les évolutions commerciales avec
la transformation des business models de
la presse en ligne
si on adopte un point de vue le verre à
moitié vide on peut voir à travers ces
évolutions des contraintes qui sont
imposés par la loi du marché et
puisqu'elle adopte un point de vue un
petit peu plus constructif
on peut dire que ces évolutions elle
nous pousse à l'innovation éditoriale
alors si on commence par le business
model de la presse en ligne
en gros il ya quatre modèles
d'abord vous avez le service public en
gros vous avez peu voire pas de
contraintes économiques
ensuite vous allez avoir le mécénat donc
là vous dépendez d'un mât riche
entrepreneur l'avantagent si vous n'avez
pas ou peu de contraintes budgétaires
l'inconvénient c'est ya un risque
d'interventionnisme qu'on connaît
ensuite vous allez avoir les abonnements
en france on a les exemples du monde et
de mediapart qui marche bien mais
l'expérience montre que ce sont des
modèles qui sont assez difficiles à
reproduire
et puis en un lieu que vous aviez la
publicité donc ça peut prendre
différentes formes que ce soit des
bannières des contenus sponsorisés des
opérations spéciales en tout cas quelle
que soit la forme le fond
même la marque veut s'associer à un
média pour y être valorisée
le problème c'est que quand on parle de
marque un journaliste ce qu'il voit
c'est ça je pense que ces journalistes
se trompent parce que la marque s'est
pas forcément le grand méchant loup
alors je dis pas non plus que la marque
est votre ami il faut pas être naïf
simplement de la marque on peut aussi la
considérer comme un partenaire de
croissance économique bien sûr mais
aussi éditorial que veut la marque la
marque d'abord elle veut a dû elle va
être vu donc elle va s'associer à un
média qui fédère la plus large que lui
n'était possible qu'ils fassent du clic
mais pas du clic à tout prix parce que
la marque
elle veut aussi elle a besoin de
véhiculer une image des valeurs et pour
cela la marque a besoin d'un public
qu'ils soient qualifiés qui
correspondent à sa cible en général un
partenaire commercial quand il a une
visée longue termiste il va vouloir
véhiculer des valeurs positives des
valeurs qui donnent envie qui ont du
sens donc la marque va vouloir
s'associer à un média qui lui même
produit du sens et c'est là qu'on en
vient à l'innovation
ce le média donc se retrouve in fine et
dans une triangulation entre d'un côté
les partenaires commerciaux qui vont lui
permettre de générer des revenus et
d'autre part les plates formes de
distribution qui vont lui permettre de
toucher le plus large public possible
que ce soit via les moteurs de recherche
ou via les réseaux sociaux
alors donc ce contexte on en vient à la
question qui concerne pleinement les
médias comment créer du contenu mon
expérience à eurosport et j'ai tiré
quatre mots clés qui aujourd'hui me
paraissent essentielles à tout bon
contenu l'incarnation l'identification
l'émotion et l'inspiration l'incarnation
d'abord
un sujet va plus vous touchez plus vous
parler s'il est porté par une équipe par
des joueurs par des acteurs dans tous
les cas par une entité incarner vous
allez le 'wti' être plus touchée par un
sujet si vous vous sentez concernés si
vous vous identifier par exemple pendant
l'euro en juin dernier les sujets chez
nous qui ennuie marché c'était le sujet
sur les supporters l'émotion l'émotion
c'est un élément qui est essentiel à
tout sujet et surtout dans le sport vous
allez pleurer de joie de tristesse dans
tous les cas vous avez réagir et si ce
qui est aussi ce qui va vous faire
retenir le sujet et puis l'inspiration
alors l'inspiration
ça va être des histoires positives des
histoires qui vont permettre de voir
l'avenir sous un meilleur angle par
exemple pendant l'euro le vrai héros
c'était qui sait pas sur qui veut gagner
c'est l'islande
souvenez-vous l'islande c'était cette
toute petite nation qui avec des moyens
minime par rapport aux autres gros géant
a réussi en est tout un peuple et a
réussi à se hisser jusqu'aux quarts de
finale pendant les jeux olympiques
on a vu aussi des histoires incroyables
et les histoires qui marche mieux
c'est pas celle des athlètes qui sont
nés avec une cuillère en argent dans la
bouche et qui sont finalement des
machines de guerre née pour gagner les
histoires qui marche le mieux ce sont
ces histoires d'hommes et de femmes qui
finalement se sont battus pour y arriver
qui à force de persévérance n'ont rien
lâché et ont fini par l'emporter
à l'image par exemple de sept athlètes
kenyans qui fait appeler you tube man et
qui a un parcours incroyable il a appris
le lancer de javelot en regardant des
vidéos sur internet
finalement facebook nous pousse à sans
cesse nous remettre en question et
notamment aujourd'hui la manière la plus
simple de le concevoir c'est de vous
dire
interrogez-vous comment est ce que vous
vous consommez l'information
l'information générale vous l'a
consommée sur votre téléphone mobile
et quand vous consommez sur votre
téléphone mobile vous êtes un scroll
permanent en mode zapping donc nous
médias on a une seconde 2 maximum pour
attirer votre attention et votre
attention
elle va être attiré par quoi les plupart
du temps c'est un élément visuel c'est
comme ça du coup à partir de cette
contrainte qu'on est venu à créer un
format qui s'appelle les bleus en et
mogi dont cliniquement sur facebook et
c'est un résumé des bleus uniquement
visuel alors on va pas se contenter de
ce format sur le site
vous avez un texte qui vous fait un
compte rendu avec l'analyse mais sur
facebook ont créé un format qui est
spécialement adaptée à la consommation
des internautes sur facebook simplement
facebook
s'il est un acteur essentiel sur le
digital c'est aussi un arbitre qui
s'imposaient ces règles par exemple
qu'est ce qu'un bon statut facebook
qu'est ce qui fait que les algorithmes
de facebook vont pousser votre statut
vers le flux de vos amis vous avez dû
observer qu'il ya deux éléments
essentiels d'abord un élément visuel les
statuts 40 le mieux sont ceux qui
comporte une photo ou une vidéo
et les statuts car manque le plus vont
être les statuts qui ont un fort
engagement
donc concrètement ça va être les statuts
qui font plus réagir avec le plus de
like le plus de commentaires
le plus de partage parce que facebook va
considérer que ce contenu et pertinents
et donc va le pousser dans le sens voulu
ces contraintes le site buzzfeed que
vous connaissez sûrement les a
génialement détourné en créant un live
vidéo interactif nous sursoierons on l'a
adapté donc là il tourne plus mais ce
que vous pouvez voir à travers l'image
de fond c'est qu'on l'adapté au sujet le
plus populaire qui soit en ce moment
c'est qui va gagner le ballon d'or
donc on a tout simplement pris une photo
sur laquelle on a mis les trois favoris
au ballon d'or ronaldo messi et
griezmann et à chacun on leur associer
un emoji et ont proposé dans ce live
vidéo aux internautes de voter
pourquoi ce type de contenu cartonne
le mans parce que ils possèdent les deux
éléments essentiels du bond de statut
une vidéo et un nombre de like qui est
ainsi un qui est poussé par le vote
c'est un énorme carton 2011 vu 15
millions de personnes atteintes
seulement ce que nous ont considéré
comme mal un mât facebook la vie d'un
autre oeil et facebook a changé les
règles
facebook est ce que j'ai les règles pas
plus tard qu'hier jeudi
depuis hier nous n'avons plus le droit
d'utiliser ce type de live vidéo new
media pour proposer aux internautes de
voter
est ce que c'est un problème bah oui
j'ai pas vous dire que ce n'est pas un
problème puisque ça nous coupe l'herbe
sous le pied on va pouvoir créer ces
contenus qui cartonne simplement on peut
aussi le voir d'un autre oeil
parce que finalement là rien de bien
méchant et cette nouvelle contrainte
elle va nous pousser à innover
éditorialement alors qu'est ce qu'on va
faire
honnêtement aujourd'hui j'en sais rien
la seule chose que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'avec l'équipe et ça va sûrement
se passer comme ça dans d'autres médias
on va se poser dans une salle on va
réfléchir et on va sortir dans quelques
jours dans quelques semaines des
nouveaux formats qui vont nous permettre
de nouveau agir avec notre communauté
pour susciter son émotion et son
inspiration
merci
[Applaudissements]